JOINING US TONIGHT.
--.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS CLOSE TO
LAUNCHING A MAJOR MILITARY
STRIKE ON IRAN.
BUT AT THE LAST-MINUTE THE
PRESIDENT PULLED BACK AND THANK
GOODNESS HE
INSTEAD OF BEING PRAISED, TRUMP
CAME UNDER ATTACK FOR THAT.
ON THE RIGHT A RADIO SHOW HOST
ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF BEING A
WEAKLING OF NOT LAUNCHING A
TRILLION DOLLARS WAR OVER A
BROKEN ROBOT.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
YESTERDAY.
I CALLED IT A U-TURN.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR ALL OF OUR DECISION MAKERS
TO RECOGNIZE THE WEAKNESS IS
PROVOCATIVE.
A WORLD IN WHICH RESPONSE TO
ATTACKS ON AMERICAN ASSETS IS TO
PULL BACK OR TO ACCEPT THE
ATTACK, IS A WORLD IN WHICH
AMERICA WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY DEFEND OUR
INTERESTS.
>> Tucker: SO IRAN IS GOING TO
INVADE NEW JERSEY BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT STARTED A WAR.
DEMOCRATS DENOUNCED THE
PRESIDENT ALSO.
TRY TO FOLLOW THE REASONING.
>> FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PRESIDENCY, TAKING A COURSE OF
ESCALATION WITH IRAN.
WE PULLED OUT OF AN ANTI-NUCLEAR
DEAL THAT GAVE US TRANSPARENCY
INTO THEIR NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> IT'S LIKE SOMEBODY SETTING A
FIRE TO A BASKET FULL OF PAPER
AND PUT IT OUT.
HE HELPED CREATE THE CRISIS AND
THEN STOPPED THE ATTACKS.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION IN MY
MIND THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IN
PLACE A SERIES OF EVENTS THAT
LED TO THAT EVENT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S KAMALA
HARRIS'S POSITION.
IT NOT TRUMP THAT IS EAGER TO
START A WAR WITH COUNTRY AFTER
COUNTRY IT'S THE REST OF
WASHINGTON STARTING WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
VANILLATE.
-- JOHN BOLTON.
THE PRESIDENT POINTED THAT OUT
ON "MEET THE PRESS" THIS
WEEKEND.
>> I HAVE DOVES AND HAWKS.
I HAVE SOME HAWKS.
JOHN BOLTON IS ABSOLUTELY A
HAWK.
IF IT WAS UP TO HIM, HE WOULD
TAKE ON THE WHOLE WORLD AT ONE
TIME.
OKAY.